all right guys we are live in studio
with the man that i believe is going to
be the next next governor of the great
state of california well the once great
state of california we're going to make
it very early we're going to make it
great again
okay here's the deal we got about three
minutes here and then i'm doing a proper
hour-long sit down with larry but we
wanted to do this portion live because
we just found out i guess yesterday
morning
that according to the secretary of state
in california you did not qualify to be
one of the 41 candidates on the list
take it away well apparently uh
there is a law that was passed in order
to make sure that donald trump turned
over his tax returns
uh for the 2020 election uh requiring
five years of tax returns
uh that was appeal all the way up to the
california supreme court it ruled
unanimously that it was unconstitutional
as to
uh the presidential elections but it was
okay as to gubernatorial elections so it
applies to me
and apparently what they're saying is of
the 250
some odd pages of stuff i turned over i
either did not redact something that
should have been redacted
or redacted something that should not
have been redacted we think it has to do
with my social security number
assuming that's true the law is designed
to protect me from anybody getting my
number
uh and then hurting me right are they my
privacy so if anybody's hurt it's me
so the intent of the law in my opinion
was not heard no lawyer that i've talked
to including several
election law specialists believe it's
going to hold up and if it is not
reversed and we're having conversations
with the secretary of state as we speak
and i don't believe it's going to be
reversed we're going to court and we're
going to win
and we'll know some you know probably in
a couple of days whether or not i'm
going to be officially on a certified
ballot but i'm going to be on
so a couple days you find out if you're
on and then if you're not on then you go
to court no no we're going to court now
to make sure i am on
oh god we'll know what the ruling will
be by buying a couple of days
uh but if we lose we're gonna appeal and
it'll go past wednesday the appeal will
yeah but i'll know one way or the other
if i'm going to be on the certified
valid by
by probably by wednesday i mean does
this feel like just
it's never happened before nobody's ever
been disqualified for something like
this
it is de minimis that lawyers say um uh
and furthermore there's a provision in
the law that allows the secretary of
state to correct
if you have redacted something or you
shouldn't have rejected something and
she elected not to do that
she's the secretary of state her name is
shirley webber she's a democrat
uh i'm not saying the fix is in on larry
older or not but can you imagine if they
tried this on al sharpton waiting for
you
be saying i'm just saying yeah well i
know the last thing that larry elder
ever wants to do is play identity
politics but i'm pretty sure
if this was a red state and a black hand
that it wouldn't be it i mean
all i don't think so david i i think the
the issue is larry elder they're
friendly
and i'm somebody that can that can speak
to minorities in ways that that many
republicans can't
and won't inhabit i gave an interview
for example to a black newspaper up in
sacramento and i said aren't you tired
aren't you tired of the fact that 75
percent of black kids cannot read at
state levels of efficiency
aren't you tired of my high school
credential high school only two percent
of kids are mad proficient aren't you
tired of this
aren't you tired of the teachers union
that is adamantly opposed to school
choice when the majority
uh black and brown parents living in the
inner city wants full choice aren't you
tired of being pushed around like this
don't you think it's time for something
new and all of a sudden their body
language changed dave
and i could tell that uh that i had i'm
not saying i won them over
but i think that nato order perceived me
to be an enemy and uncle tom a sellout
which is often what people call me
yeah all right we're gonna do the rest
of this as a proper sit down all right
everybody knows that you were an
integral piece of my wake up so that
really could be your
that's really you know you could become
governor but it's more integral piece to
my popularity my popularity shot up
after
the interview with you i didn't know who
you were yeah one of my young friends
said you want to interview with him
his name his name is dave rubin he's a
short guy and i said never heard it
you got to talk to him and all of a
sudden a bunch of young people who
didn't know me from adam began to
uh follow me on twitter and facebook and
instagram so i owed you a great deal of
debt
right you bludgeoned me in front of
millions i'm scared they're still
cleaning up the blood
somebody called a cut man all right go
to elect elder
calm help larry out this is this is our
chance today
you're always asking me dave why are you
staying in california this is the chance
right here
right we're doing a proper hour-long sit
down right now